we adopted a baby
her name is lily oh exciting
just turn it off i can't turn it off
it's who i am
the music yes
emergency assistance this is trina well
we locked our baby in the car and people
are judging us
do not break the window you'll get glass
on her sir please tell your wife to
relax
everything is going to be okay that's a
man really don't worry lily
lily daddy's coming for you sir we just
sent the signal the door should be
unlocked check out
check the door check the door check the
door it's not unlocked
oh oh okay that is amazing
how did they do that i don't know it's
just we got it thank you you come from
spain we met at one of pepper's
legendary game nights i remember
mitchell because he
kept rolling his eyes every time i would
get a little boisterous i did not
a little bit yeah maybe a little bit
we were we were playing charades and i i
had no idea how to act on my clue and
all i could think of
to do was and without missing a beat
cam says casablanca all i did was this
casablanca
[Music]
casablanca
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tonight we dine on the traditional
colombian recipes of my abuela
my grandmother and even though she's no
longer with me
i am very happy because i have all of
you
tu ana maria rosa de la immaculada
jimenez morales
morales it's beautiful gloria just like
my mitchell
slipped right out there day four of the
juice fast
and i'm hungry but i'm i'm feeling
pretty good
cam on the other hand has gone all girl
interrupted
after one throwing out all of our food
and two blaming me
he entered stage three soap actress
i just wish my sister would put herself
out there more if she had so much to
offer
why are men so superficial
that was followed by stage four a rush
of epiphanies
i don't need food
oh look at this architecture's
everywhere oh spaniards make amazing
athletes
into stage five despair
daddy we hide it but you didn't
seek cam then came rage
[Applause]
hey what you got there all right guys
that's it
pack it up you win for today
see you on monday that's it that's it
so i'll go to city hall on monday and
see what i can do but
you didn't cam no we did it i had to run
away and you stepped in and like an
understudy you gave a brilliant
performance
yeah but you're the star
can we stop doing this and go home
yes lily but i want you to remember this
moment the day your daddy's made you
proud
is that my cam chair graham graham
[Applause]
there's been some storm warning so marge
thought she'd be safer over here when
she dropped her off so fast that we
didn't even have a chance to straighten
up oh
we never told graham about the gay you
know after they reach a certain age you
worry that it could be the thing that
sends them over the edge and she's been
on the edge for a long time
we're actually on deathbed number two
mitchell
mitchell okay what what's this this is
me ready to slop
bail or milk something you don't need to
do that no i did cam
i i know i know i gave you hell for for
being who you really are and i want to
make that up to you yeah but you
know what putting on my sister's sunday
overalls is gesture enough what's this
oh it's my chewing straw it's not strong
oh it's just show okay for sure
come on you know you love the man you
love the world he comes from yeah i
don't know if it's these farming clothes
or what but i am feeling so
close to you right now that's so sweet
give me a kiss not right now
well don't make me wrastle you down
who's this oh dear uh well grams this is
bud
our new farm hand bud
yeah bud's a little simple-minded on
account of getting mule kicked
idney and you know the rules on being in
the house but now go on outside
we're gonna milk the cows in a few
minutes get on out there
have a treat afterwards this
is not at all how i saw the evening
going
oh honey you have no idea
do you remember our first apartment yes
what
what made you think of that i don't know
the stars
all right come on let's do this yeah
[Music]
yes we're gathered here today to join
two amazing people
so naturally i was a little picky when
it came to who was going to be replacing
me
and then i met this cam and sure he was
warm and
funny and loving
cameron do you take mitchell to be your
husband i do
cameron would you please place this ring
on mitchell's finger
[Music]
mitchell do you take cameron to be your
husband
i do then by the powers vested in me by
the state of california i am privileged
to pronounce you
spouses for life you may now kiss your
[Music]
husband
okay listen i know how lucky i am to
have you but i can't possibly
keep up with this level of affection
oh boy i apologize i'm a monster no
obviously i'm the monster
obviously you know can i just point out
that when we were in cabo
you didn't seem to mind all the flowers
or the back rubs or the attention
well that was our honeymoon and yes i
loved it but it was weeks ago
well maybe some of us don't want it to
end
well it has to eventually and
all right cam did you have this lipstick
you know personally i feel sorry for you
that you're so
shut off that a few simple romantic oh
my god
what am i looking at here well i guess
i'm crazy because
i've taken pictures of you sleeping
every night since we got married
because you're the man of my dreams
super quick if i was the man of your
dreams wouldn't you have to be the one
sleeping
don't pull that thread mitchell speaking
of which what is don't pull that thread
mitchell
oh cam come on even you have to admit
this is excessive
excessive really oh struck by cupid's
magic
air hey mr pritchett there is a
connecting flight through dallas that
leaves in five minutes you can catch it
if you hurry
i don't want to go to dallas we're going
to turks and caicos dallas is just where
you make your connection
i'm sorry i'm having a really hard time
processing information right now yeah we
took sleeping bills
just make your way over to gate 32. okay
okay i can wow
wait why do these say dallas sorry
there's been a horrible mistake
we don't want to go to dallas okay
listen carefully you're connecting
in dallas to turks and caicos you need
to be at gate 32
in four minutes do you understand yes
i'm not an idiot
okay we have to be at cape 4 at 32 no
gate 32 write it down
okay oh why is she so angry it's not
obvious she's totally into me she gave
me a mocker that makes sense all right
okay
i'm gonna follow you okay wrong
anyways instinct are you sure we put the
car seat in right what do you mean we
i i don't know it felt shaky oh god this
is bad this is really
bad we don't have diapers we don't have
formulas i don't even know where we live
if somebody asks for an address what am
i supposed to say some new house
someplace
guys oh my gosh oh oh my god oh my god
we're awful
we haven't even checked in with you you
you must be freaking out too
no i'm not and neither are you this is
just your process
you get hysterical you worry about every
detail then you turn on each other
no we don't yes we do how dare you and
after all that craziness when it really
matters the most you
what what what do we do
our son he's beautiful
we got this
you